a chess game so beautiful that even
Magnus Carlson cryptically checked in on
it snow Petrov for us today and this is
the second Moment of Truth Bishop is off
to B5 so we have another Roy Lopez after
getting an opening Advantage nepo
started increasing the pressure sinking
a knight into F5 and then clamping down
on the light squares with the beautiful
sequence G4 and we call it a G4 already
on the board he played at instill Rook
E4 oh my God G5 and Rook G4
breaking through a spectacular mate
would have ensued in the main line
and now you realize that F6 is losing
for the snap h4h6 beautiful we're gonna
have that on the game I think ding is
going to play F6 again what else do you
do you don't allow when I take G5 I
think we are gonna have F6 Knight H4
ding struggled on reaching an end game
but nepo never slipped securing the win
with more than an hour on the clock ding
slumped back in his chair knowing that
he had given away game five of the fide
World Championship